it is rooted in the recognition that
foreign economic and domestic policy are
inextricably linked and that domestic
competitiveness national security and a
strong middle class are mutually
reinforcing
and that was precisely the agenda we
executed against over the last few days
in italy and the uk
just look at the priorities from the
trip
first in rome the president cemented
progress on the global minimum tax
a major achievement secured through
american and in this case through
presidential leadership that will help
stop a global corporate race to the
bottom and improve our capacity to make
investments in workers and in
communities at home and earlier today
you heard from one of our senior
officials
offering some more context on the gmt
second we took joint steps with europe
to re-establish historical transatlantic
trade flows and steel and aluminum
providing a relief to american companies
and to american consumers across the
board additionally we're laser focused
on lower lowering energy prices and
securing our supply chains on the latter
we worked with our partners to ensure
stable secure global supply chains for
critical goods medicine and technology
that the american people and the
american economy depend on
we further advance the build back better
world initiative the so-called b3w
initiative which promotes a high
standard climate-friendly global
infrastructure
around the world b3w
indeed helps our partners overseas but
it also helps american firms and
american workers compete globally on
every aspect of infrastructure from the
physical to the digital to the health
realm as well
and of course in glasgow we confronted
climate change an existential challenge
but also the greatest economic
opportunity of our time and you've heard
the president make this point repeatedly
including uh in his remarks yesterday in
glasgow we can and will create
good-paying union jobs and new
industries as we address the climate
crisis during cop 26 president biden and
secretary blinken
held productive meetings with leaders
from around the globe to step up that
global ambition and action in tackling
the climate crisis they demonstrated
that the united states is back in the
paris agreement back at the table and
back to leading the with the power of
our example they demonstrated our
commitment to support those from the
front lines of the climate crisis
we accelerated our progress through
diplomacy in a number of ways we reached
an agreement by more than 100 countries
representing 85 percent of the world's
forest to stop deforestation by 2030. we
release the u s long term strategy to
outline how we'll get to a net zero
economy
uh by twenty fifty we developed the
methane the us methane emissions
reduction action plan uh which included
new robust rules that will reduce
emissions that will cut consumer costs
and support job growth
we announced more than 100 governments
including some of the world's biggest
emitters have now joined the global
methane pledge we created partnerships
like net zero worlds the clean energy
demand initiative and first movers
coalition to drive innovation and new
technology and we establish the
president's emergency plan for
adaptation and resilience or prepare as
the acronym goes to support climate
adaptation efforts for more than a half
a billion people around the world
this must be a whole of society effort
not only from nations around the world
but also the private sector
philanthro philanthropies and others who
are dedicating themselves to climate
action uh including climate activists
around the world action by state local
and tribal governments paired with
societal leadership is what propelled
america forward and brought down
emissions even as
we were faced with the task of
reentering the paris agreement in the
earliest days of this administration on
the first day of this administration the
president underscored that investing in
a clean energy future is an enormous
opportunity for every country to create
good paying jobs and spur our economic
recovery
which is what
his framework will do it will be
the largest investment in american
history to combat the climate crisis it
will cut emissions by well over one
gigaton and 2030. it will save consumers
money on their energy bills provide tax
credits to install solar panels and
weatherize homes leverage manufacturing
credits to ensure u.s energy is clean
and competitive and accelerate our shift
to electric vehicles and school buses
this is about jobs it's about
competitiveness versus complacency as
you heard from the president the
president yesterday from glasgow this is
about making the world a safer cleaner
healthier place for children all around
the world
it's in the interest of every single
nation to act and to make a generational
investment in our climate resilience and
in our workers and communities that is
precisely what the united states
is doing and what we will continue to do
second i am pleased to announce the
appointment of ambassador william h
moser as the director of the bureau of
overseas buildings up buildings
operations or obo
this appointment underscores the
importance placed on the mission and the
work of obo to build and operate secure
sustainable technologically innovative
and resilient diplomatic platforms that
are produced by
the best in american architecture
construction and facility management
ambassador moser was a familiar face
around obo as he served as obio's
principal deputy director from 2015 to
2017 an acting director from 2017 to
2018. he's held several senior
leadership positions as a member of the
senior foreign service including as
ambassador to moldova and kazakhstan
and has demonstrated leadership and
management skills needed to provide
the global platform to advance u.s
policy overseas we look forward to
obio's achievements and contributions to
us diplomacy uh around under his
leadership and we welcome ambassador
moser to the job so with that happy to
take your questions
okay
thank you and welcome back i hope you
enjoyed uh
rome and glasgow
with what without us
yeah without us well i'm sure that that
was an added bonus everyone uh everyone
was welcome no one was excluded
um
uh let's start with uh ethiopia because
we understand that um ambassador feltman
is going to be going there possibly
other places
so if i could kind of
combine this with sudan because they
happen to be next to each other and
they're both in his
portfolio
um
what's he going to be doing in ethiopia
is he going to sudan
you just put out this joint statement
with the
brits with the saudis and the emiratis
what do you expect out of that if
anything from the other
mainly the saudis and the emiratis from
the others who are on that and uh is he
going anywhere else
sure uh let me start with ethiopia then
we'll uh move to uh sudan obviously a
lot of uh action and activity to speak
to uh when it comes to ethiopia let me
make the point that we are gravely
concerned
by the escalating violence by the
expansion of the fighting that we've
seen in northern ethiopia and in regions
throughout the country
we are concerned with the growing risk
to the unity and the integrity of the
ethiopian state
the safety of u.s citizens u.s
government personnel their dependence
and the security of our facility remains
among our highest priorities and we note
the nationwide state of emergency
declared by ethiopia's council of
ministers and we urge all parties to use
restraints end hostilities and ensure
civilians
and their rights are
respected
as the
secretary said uh just a couple days ago
uh we have been alarmed by reports uh of
the tplf takeover um in of deci and
kambolcha
continued fighting only prolongs the
humanitarian crisis
that is afflicting far too many people
in ethiopia today all parties all
parties must stop military operations
and begin ceasefire negotiations uh
without preconditions uh many of you
also uh saw that ambassador feltman uh
delivered remarks at the u.s institute
for peace uh yesterday on ethiopia uh
where he made uh some of these uh same
points um
we are not only uh engaged in diplomacy
ourselves uh but we are working with
international partners uh to address the
crisis in ethiopia including through
action with the u.n the african union
other relevant partners and and bodies
as well
you are correct that ambassador feltman
will be traveling to uh ethiopia on
november 4th and november 5th um
he will be traveling there because we as
i said before are increasingly troubled
uh by uh the expansion of combat
operations and intercommunal violence uh
in parts of ethiopia uh and we are
closely monitoring the situation
we call on all ethiopians to commit to
peace and resolution of grievances
through dialogue and ambassador feltman
in his travels there
will have an opportunity
to
continue the discussions that have been
ongoing um including with uh the
ethiopian government uh for uh some time
now uh in terms of any follow-on travel
um we have confirmed that he's traveling
to
ethiopia
tomorrow
november 4th don't have any additional
travel to announce at this time but of
course we'll keep you posted
if his plans
do change
let me go on to sudan because this is
also
an area
that falls
under ambassador feltman's
remit
and of course there too
we have been working concertedly
over
the past week plus and over the weekend
we saw a remarkable demonstration of the
aspirations of the sudanese people we
applaud the millions of sudanese who
came out on october 30th they came out
to defend the country's revolution
to make clear that their democratic
aspirations
have not been
abated
they were clear that sudan's democratic
transition must continue
we join them
we call for the civilian-led
transitional government established
under the 2019 constitutional
declaration to be restored
we are steadfast in standing with
sudan's people on their path of freedom
peace and justice
we do regret the loss of life that has
occurred in recent days
and we stand in solidarity with the
family and friends of those
of those who were killed those who have
been
wounded and we joined the sudanese
people in calling for justice and
accountability for violations
and abuses of
human rights
matt you referred to a joint statement
that came out just a few minutes ago
this was a joint statement by the quad
for sudan to translate that is a
grouping of the kingdom of saudi arabia
the united arab emirates the united
kingdom
and the united states
i
i would like to
call your attention to really the crux
of this statement
these four countries the united states
included came together to make clear
that quote we call for the full and
immediate restoration of its sudans
civilian-led transitional government
institutions we call upon all parties to
strive for cooperation and unity in
reaching this critical objective
it goes on to say in that vein we
encourage the release of all those
detained in connection with the recent
events and the lifting of the state of
emergency as you know uh in both rome uh
in glasgow the secretary had an
opportunity to meet with a number of uh
his counterparts we met with uh foreign
minister
with the saudi foreign minister we met
with the emirati foreign minister
we met
with others who
have
a stake
in a stable
democratic civilian-led
sudan and this was
the message we've heard so it is not
just the united states calling for the
immediate restoration the civilian-led
government
in sudan it is
much of the international community that
is coming together in this case uh that
includes the united kingdom uh but it
includes uh some of sudan's uh regional
neighbors and partners uh saudi arabia
and the united arab emirates uh we are
not alone in this we are very much
united uh with our allies with our
partners around the world on the
imperative of a swift return to
democratic governance a swift return to
the civilian-led transition
in sudan and we will continue to work
with our partners
to bring that about we also know um even
as we um push this forward
that failure to do so failure to restore
civilian-led government in sudan
will only further isolate sudan from the
international community we've already
talked about the suspension
of
our own emergency support funding some
700 million dollars
that were suspended uh in the immediate
aftermath of the military takeover uh
last week but beyond that more than four
billion in international assistance from
bilateral partners and international uh
financial institutions and at least 19
billion in international debt relief is
already at risk
we and as i said before the broader
international community are committed to
supporting the sudanese people
and their legitimate aspirations for
freedom for peace uh and for justice uh
as well but not just
on these two countries and specif
specifically the administration and and
and just in terms of the administration
and not uh the saudis the emiratis or
anyone else but just this administration
you guys have been warning both of these
countries for months now about against
uh you know leaders in these countries
against taking these actions you've had
a parade of officials
a mini parade of officials go through
both including samantha power including
ambassador feldman himself who was
in khartoum just hours before
you know this this coup happened
you have that now suspended 700 million
in uh assistance to sudan you have
kicked agoa or are about to kick
ethiopia out of
the african growth and opportunity act
and they don't seem to be listening
listening
is there do you have any concern that
your your message is not being uh heated
or that you're being ignored
uh matt obviously i don't want to group
sudan and ethiopia
and treat them as one of the same these
are very distinct cases
treat them as the same but they happen
to be
right next to each other and they happen
to be the horn of africa which is the
the portfolio of ambassador phil well
and that's precisely why ambassador
feltman was in sudan in the first place
uh he has been uh a frequent visitor
to sudan uh in recent weeks uh to work
on a number of issues
including the gerd but also
our concern
for the viability
of the
civilian-led transitional government
given some of the indications that the
international community had seen uh in
the weeks and the days uh preceding the
military takeover
that something uh was afoot there
so
again i don't
want you to confuse
um
uh
i don't want you to think this
relationship is causal um he was there
no no no
i'm wondering no i'm not saying it's
your fault or his fault or whoever i'm
just asking you if you are concerned
that the message that you have been
delivering to both in both of these
countries
over the course of the last several
months hasn't been listened to these are
these are difficult challenges these are
difficult challenges
again to take each separately because
these are separate challenges uh in
sudan
the pace of the democratic transition uh
has been a source of frustration for
some uh the fact that uh ambassador
feltman has been such a regular visitor
there had been such a regular visitor is
indicative of some of the challenges
that the international community
recognized uh the uh civilian-led uh
transitional government
was encountering
we have been there uh ambassador feltman
has been there we've spoken out we've
engaged in private diplomacy to indicate
our support uh for the civilian-led
transitional government um
now of course
uh the uh the military uh as we saw the
other week had other plans in mind uh
but it is notable that you have seen uh
the international community uh including
some of uh sudan's most important
regional neighbors uh swiftly condemn
these anti-democratic actions
call for the immediate restoration of
the civilian-led transitional
government and have made clear in no
uncertain terms where they stand and
they stand with united states they stand
with the international community in
making clear that the military's
takeover
must not uh be allowed to stand now of
course ethiopia is a separate challenge
this is something that we have been hard
at work on uh from the earliest days of
this administration the violence of
course predates uh this administration
uh tomorrow i believe november 4th marks
one year uh of conflict in tigre it's
one year of uh devastating implications
uh for the people of tigre uh in in
recent months in recent weeks we've seen
the violence escalate we've seen the
violence uh spread uh to other uh
regions but here too uh we have been
working very closely uh with our
partners including uh those uh in the
african union and un uh to make clear
to all of the parties the ethio
ethiopian government the tplf uh eritrea
that
these hostilities must come to an end
and
the path forward lies in diplomacy the
path forward uh lies in um negotiations
uh that should start immediately and
without preconditions uh to put an end
to the violence but importantly to
ensure that the people of ethiopia the
people of tigre
have access to the humanitarian supplies
humanitarian assistance that they so
desperately need and when it comes to
that humanitarian assistance no country
has done more than the united states
to
provide
the people of ethiopia
with these life life-saving
assistance and supplies
we'll continue to do that
but it is also why as we made clear
yesterday that any effort to hinder
humanitarian assistance to hinder the
delivery of humanitarian aid will be met
with
a significant response uh in using all
appropriate tools uh and yesterday we
spoke of
another uh tool that may be called upon
on january 1st
if we do not see a change
in conduct when it comes to
human rights abuses and the provision of
humanitarian aid and access yes
so this was a statement that was put
forward by the quad for sudan uh and the
quad for sudan includes us includes our
british partners our emirati partners
and our saudi partners uh sudan is an
issue that we have discussed uh with a
number of um
uh
countries in the region uh and well
beyond we've been in we've been in
contact uh with our uh counterparts in
egypt uh as well knowing that uh the
more we
speak and act with one voice
the more our message
the clearer our message will be
to
those in sudan our affirmative message
that we stand with the sudanese people
including the millions who took to the
streets
over the last weekend who took to the
streets peacefully i should emphasize
but also to uh
general burhan and and those behind
this military takeover
that their actions will not be tolerated
that the international community will
not
stand by
unless they return sudan
to
civilian rule and its transitional
government
the military does not have the ability
to select
sudan's civilian leaders
that is very clear the 2019 uh
transitional constitution is very clear
uh on that front and that's what we'll
continue to stand by but why why egypt
didn't sign on this day you'll have
you'll have to ask the egyptians
you'll you'll you'll have to ask the
egyptians for
uh uh
you know a uh for their position on this
what i can tell you is this was put
forward by the quad for sudan uh the
quad for sudan includes us and includes
our british partners our emirati
partners uh and our saudi uh partners
there are a number of countries uh who
around the world
who are in um
complete and total agreement with the
united states and with these countries
with other countries that the military's
takeover
is unacceptable
and that it must be immediately reversed
again this was a statement by the quad
for sudan you have heard other countries
speak out you've heard other countries
uh make that message very clear but i'm
not here to speak for other countries
i'm here to speak for the united states
yes
has there been any direct engagement
from the administration ambassador
feldman or anyone else with the
militaries with general abraham in the
last days and
do you sense that there is some path
from openness to to
to going back to the status quo and
from the military right now do you have
some openness uh do you see somehow
uh so i will say that there has been
engagement um from uh individuals in
this building of course we read out uh
secretary lincoln's discussion with uh
prime minister hamduk
there has been engagement from others in
this building
to the sudanese military to make very
clear where the united states where
the international community stands i
wouldn't want to characterize
those discussions um but we have left no
ambiguity whatsoever
about uh
what the international community is very
clear
that needs to happen and that is a swift
restoration of the civilian-led
transitional government we've been very
clear um about the potential
implications and costs uh if this
military takeover uh is not reversed uh
we have already taken action to that end
in terms of suspending the 700 million
dollars in bilateral assistance
and as i said before there are billions
upon billions uh at stake uh in terms of
debt relief in terms of um uh financing
from international lending institutions
uh if the sudanese military uh is
unwilling to uh relent but this is
something that we are working at uh day
in day out uh with uh our
uh with sudanese interlocutors uh but
also with partners in the region we'll
be on site
could you explain to it the israeli role
with the sudanese
because there was a delegation
that visited with uh brahan general
rohan and so on and today just now as a
matter of fact
an israeli website wallah
claims that you guys have asked
israel to help you know and sort of
reverse the
the uh the have you done that are you in
touch with the israelis to basically you
know
convince the sudanese that they should
you know back that abraham should
backtrack we have been in touch uh at
very senior levels uh with very senior
interlocutors
throughout the region and beyond and
that includes with israel
that includes with israel um but again i
i'm gonna leave that those diplomatic
discussions and diplomatic channels um
but we have discussed this with
virtually
everyone with a stake
in
democratic stable peaceful sudan and
that is just about everyone in the
region and many countries will be on the
region
i want to just drill down specifically
on you know there's talk of of prime
minister hamdock um being restored to
his position you know is that is that
sufficient um
for the
international acceptance that you you
were kind of talking about
and you mentioned um the protesters in
sudan on on saturday um
a lot of those people out on the streets
they're you know
rather than calling for the status quo
auntie they're actually saying
you know these coup leaders have have
breached the trust of this transition
and the military should fully withdraw
from
sudanese politics you know is that is
that a realistic um
uh aim and
you know would
would it be sufficient just to return to
where things were before
what we are calling for uh and what
you've seen our partners call for
including in the context of the quad
statement
that came out today
is
a restoration of the 2019 constitutional
declaration uh and what that established
uh was a civilian-led uh government um
a civilian-led government that worked in
partnership with the sudanese military
i'm not going to offer a road map from
here about
what that restoration might look like in
practice what we are focused on uh is a
restoration of that underlying framework
the 2019
constitutional declaration
that in turn
will dictate what is and what is not
acceptable
because it is a document that is uh
sudanese and origin
and it is uh has been endorsed uh and
has been the the the blueprint um for uh
the past several years and that's what
uh we continue to stand by that's what
the sudanese people continue to stand by
uh including with the massive
demonstrations peaceful demonstrations
uh that we saw in sudan over the weekend
uh anything else on sudan yes abby
on ethiopia anything uh
sure afghanistan let's we'll come back
to that uh
great uh ethiopia given the escalating
levels of violence in ethiopia is there
any change to the status of the us
embassy or any consideration uh of
authorized departure
so as i've said uh the
safety uh security of uh american
citizens in ethiopia uh is our uh uh is
among our highest priorities we are
always looking at the security situation
to determine uh what is um appropriate
given um
the conditions on the ground our embassy
in addis remains open it remains
operational
as you may know
on november 3rd today we did update the
travel advisory for ethiopia to level
four
what that means is we are advising u.s
citizens
do not travel
to ethiopia we are recommending that u.s
citizens in
ethiopia
consider departing now using
commercial options that remain available
we understand that commercial commercial
activity continues uh commercial
air traffic continues uh in and out of
uh addis
those options uh remain available
and we are uh urging american citizens
uh to look into those options on
november 2nd yesterday
we released a security alert to u.s
citizens and by advising them
that
u.s embassy personnel are currently
restricted from traveling
outside the city limits of of addis
ababa
the security alert also strongly
suggests
that u.s citizens seriously reconsider
travel to ethiopia
and those who are in ethiopia consider
making preparations to leave so of
course the security situation has
evolved even over the past 24 hours and
today we did issue that level 4 travel
advisory urging americans to depart the
country now
using commercial options beyond the
messaging that our embassy in addis is
putting forward we are also
reaching out to the diaspora community
here in
the united states
and
around the world
to ensure that to ensure wide
distribution of these messages
when it comes to u.s citizens
who may be
in ethiopia we will continue to provide
the latest and the best information we
have to the american citizen community
in
ethiopia
going forward
sure ethiopia
hold on
didn't you guys go to authorized
departure for um
families and non-essential non-emergency
personnel last week
on wednesday
we'll double check but um uh obviously
we we do make these public uh i don't
believe that
i don't believe that's out there but we
did issue a level four travel advisory
today
just as you mentioned the united nations
and
african union
what do you think they could do to help
the crisis in ethiopia
would the u.s support
a security council meeting on on
ethiopia or is the u.s supporting one
and um or what can neighboring countries
do uh you mentioned eritrea are there
others uh what would you have that would
you have those organizations
well when it comes to eritrea uh and the
role that eritrean forces have been
playing in ethiopia we've been very
clear for some time uh about the urgent
need for eritrean forces to withdraw
from ethiopia they have been
contributing to uh the violence
contributing to the instability uh
contributing to
uh the increasing uh humanitarian
emergency that has afflicted uh far too
many uh ethiopians in tigre
and uh in regions uh beyond tigre at
this point uh we have uh when it comes
to ethiopia more broadly we've been
working uh in lockstep with uh the
african union um
well beyond well before uh the uh recent
violence uh escalated the african union
has uh an important role uh to play in
this the united nations uh has an
important role uh to play in this uh
when we were in new york city for the
u.n general assembly in september there
were a number of discussions uh on the
increasing threats to peace and
stability uh and security in uh ethiopia
uh and again we're exploring uh all
options that may be appropriate
given the actions given the inaction of
the various parties uh in ethiopia above
all we are calling on the ethiopian
government we are calling on
the tplf uh we are calling on uh
eritrean forces uh to withdraw
we are calling on all parties uh to
engage uh in uh dialogue
uh to use restraints
to end hostilities
and to ensure civilians and their rights
are protected we have a number of tools
that are
disposal both positive and negative
incentives for
various parties we put some of those on
the table we've utilized uh some of
those and we will continue to calibrate
our response based on what we see based
on what we don't see in the days and the
weeks going forward uh
iran anything else on ethiopia
iran
iran just announced that the the
negotiations in vienna will resume in
on november 29th can you confirm that
you
will be
there
not directly but indirectly to to be
part of those negotiations
well um we understand that uh
the
european external action service of
course has been coordinating
with the iranians on their stated intent
to resume negotiations uh before the end
of this month
this appears to have just taken place
but we do welcome the eu's announcement
uh that they have coordinated with all
participants and that talks on a mutual
return to compliance
with the jcpoa
will resume for a seventh round on
monday november 29th
special envoy mali will again
lead u.s participation in these talks
we've said this many times before but we
believe it remains possible
to quickly reach and implement an
understanding on a mutual return to
compliance with the jcpoa um by closing
the
relatively small number of issues uh
that remained outstanding at the end of
june when the sixth round concluded
we believe that if the iranians are
serious
we
can manage to do that
in relatively short order but we've also
been clear including as this pause has
dragged on for uh some time that this
window of opportunity will not uh be
open forever um and that uh
especially if iran continues to take
provocative
nuclear steps and together with the iaea
we've expressed our concern about a
number
of those steps in recent days
in recent weeks so we certainly hope
that when the iranian delegation returns
to vienna later this month they do so
ready to negotiate
they do so
ready to
negotiate
quickly and
in good faith as well
uh site
sure okay very quickly uh now
there's been a letter signed by 200
members of uh republican members of
congress there's a great deal of uh push
around town from pressure groups and so
on for you guys not to go through with
the reopening of the consulate can you
put this issue to rest and state the
american commitment or the state
department's commitment to reopening
the jerusalem consulate
we have been very clear about this in
may uh the we were very clear in october
uh we don't have anything new uh to
offer so the conflict will reopen at one
point we we've been very clear uh about
our intentions uh you've heard this from
the secretary on a number of times now a
couple more issues there's also been a
report by the united nations that says
that home demolitions palestinian home
dimension by the ireland occupation
forces increased by 21
do you have any comment on that
we've also been clear on this issue um
we believe it is uh critical for
uh the parties to refrain from
unilateral action that exacerbate
tensions and that undercut uh
efforts to advance negotiated two-state
solution
that certainly includes home demolitions
and lastly your favorite topic
settlements you know i know that you
guys gave a very strong statement and so
on but then the israelis they come
around and in fact the prime minister's
office you claim that you are not going
to do anything you're not going to
pressure israel to you know you you will
you know that will be the extent of it
you know just the the statement
that is strongly uh
it's not even condemning but
strongly opposing uh the settlement
process now i know mrs sullivan has met
or me is meeting in israel uh with you
know on
iran but also on uh construction
can you update us on the latest or you
latest position on this
well uh we have stated our position on
this uh in in recent days uh our
position has not changed uh you heard me
discuss uh our position on steps
unilateral steps that exacerbate
tensions
and that put a negotiated two-state
solution further out of reach we
continue to believe that settlement
activity
falls in that category hold
on uh
last week there was a i realize you
weren't here but there was a delegation
or at least one guy from israel who came
to explain or to give you further
explanation about the uh designations of
the palestinian six palestinian ngos as
terrorist organizations
other than saying that you met with him
and you received
his information can you say if you've
gone over it and what you make of the
of the information that he presented and
whether you agree with the designations
i said last week that we look forward to
receiving the delegation we look forward
to
hearing additional uh details underlying
these designations uh there were uh
discussions last week we appreciated the
opportunity uh to hear directly from our
israeli partners on this but beyond that
i wouldn't want to go into the details
of it so does that mean that you have no
position at all on the designations uh
it means that i'm not going to go into
uh discussions that uh were private uh
what about me
do you have do you have an opinion one
way or the other on the israeli
designation of these six ngos as
terrorist organizations i i don't have
an update for you we've been very clear
um about
we've been very clear uh about the
importance of a vibrant civil society uh
around the world uh the united states
will continue uh to support that in each
and every context uh but i don't have an
update for you i get it regarding you
understand that's an extremely broad
answer to an extremely specific question
about
your specific question implicates uh
private diplomatic discussions that may
well have uh included i want to know
that classified information as well look
a lot of your allies in europe have come
out and taken a stance
about these designations
why don't you are you just not ready to
yet weird you never
uh matt i don't want to say never um
what i will say is that we just don't
have an update to offer for you now
lincoln has met in glasgow with the
lebanese prime minister and with the uae
foreign minister on lebanon to reconcile
between lebanon and the uae countries
what did he
was he able to achieve anything on this
and what are you working on specifically
well uh when it comes to lebanon and its
relations uh with uh it's it's uh
gulf uh neighbors um we urge that all
diplomatic channels remain open between
the parties to ensure meaningful
dialogue uh on the pressing issues
facing lebanon you're right that we had
an opportunity yesterday in glasgow to
meet with uh prime minister makati we
had an opportunity yesterday to meet
with the emirati foreign minister we had
an opportunity the day before that
to meet with the saudi foreign minister
and in each and every one of those
discussions as indicated by the readouts
and the tweets that we released
there was a discussion uh of lebanon
and the crux of that discussion uh was
the challenges the significant
challenges um
including the economic challenges and
hardship hardships that lebanon faces
and the united states continues to work
with our partners including
our saudi partners our emirati partners
in this case our french partners who
have also
played a signif significant role here
and in close coordination with
prime minister makati and the lebanese
government
to
see to it that we can do all we can to
support the lebanese people to support
their
humanitarian
needs
and their growing humanitarian needs in
light of the economic challenges
that lebanon faces
so again we'd refer you to
these to our golf partners
to explain uh and to speak to their
positions but our position is that uh
diplomatic channels uh should remain
open uh if we are to
uh seek to improve uh the humanitarian
conditions of the lebanese people uh
seek to improve uh the economic and
broader challenges that lebanon faces
today
you know how this crisis
exploded there was basically a statement
by the minister of information before he
became minister where he says that the
war in in yemen was nihilistic
something like that and the houthis were
defending themselves do you agree or
disagree with with the with the premise
of his statement that you do you call
for his resignation you know and
do you feel that this was blown way out
proportion for instance
uh
we aren't going to
uh offer a position on
uh his employment um what we can say
what i can say uh is that the notion uh
that the houthis have been anything
but a destabilizing force and a force
that has inflicted additional hardship
on the people of yemen
that is not uh an idea that we recognize
we have been very clear in condemning
the houthis
assault including their ongoing assault
on
marab other parts of yemen as well
the houthis
despite their claims to the contrary
have been
a primary cause of the hardship that the
people of yemen
face today there have been credible
proposals put on the table
proposals that the republic of yemen
government proposals that
saudi authorities
have also
been behind
that on which the houthis have so far
been unwilling to
engage so i will leave it to the
lebanese government
to speak to
the status of any ministers that may or
may not
be within the coalition but when it
comes to houthi activity when it comes
to houthi conduct we've been very clear
about where the united states stands
to solve the problem we believe that
diplomatic relations the channels of
communication uh
between lebanon and its partners uh
should remain open uh we support steps
that help advance that
but we're just processing this news so
um i'm just wondering when these talks
resume at the end of november
um is it the u.s understanding that
they're going to resume where they left
off or that you guys are going to have
to go back to ground zero given there's
new iranian leadership we've been very
clear that uh the talks if they are to
succeed uh if we are to close the
remaining areas of disagreement uh they
should start precisely where the sixth
round of talks left off
as you alluded to yourself
this announcement is is just emanating
today
so we're not in a position to uh offer
too much beyond that
but we have been uh
unambiguous uh when it comes to our
position that there was tremendous
progress achieved uh in rounds one
through six
of these talks
in vienna it would be neither uh
productive uh nor wise to
take up from any other position uh from
where we left off uh in june at the
conclusion of the sixth round and just
one more question on that so i know you
guys have said there's no exact timeline
for when parties can no longer return to
the deal or it'll be useless
but rob malley said i think earlier or
last month that there's no chronological
clock
it's a technological clock at some time
so
how far
do the iranians have to go technically
for the deal to no longer
be useful in the eyes of the u.s
i
what we don't want to do is to provide
the iranians or anyone else uh with a
blueprint uh as to how they may push uh
the envelope uh we've been uh quite
clear rob malley has made this quite
clear uh secretary blinken has made this
clear the president uh has made this
clear we still believe
there is a window
in which we can achieve a mutual return
to compliance with the joint
comprehensive plan of action
we still
believe that's viable we still believe
that is in our national interest
precisely because it would once again
impose permanent and verifiable limits
uh on uh
iran's nuclear program and it would
foreclose
iran's ability to ever acquire uh a
nuclear weapon but we've also uh made
the point that at some point uh iran's
the advancements iran has made uh the
know-how that iran has garnered
throughout this process
will make a return to the jcpoa as it
was
written and finalized in 2015 and
implemented in 2016
not worth it as a proposition
for the united states and our partners
we are not there yet
rob
has made the point as you as you pointed
out that
these are assessments based on our
understanding of a number of factors uh
our understanding of what the iranians
uh are have been doing uh in the interim
our understanding of what the so-called
breakout time uh may be that is to say
the time it would take
iran to produce the fissile material
needed
for a nuclear weapon if they chose to
pursue one um we are continuing with uh
our partners with our partners in the p5
plus one uh with our uh allies and
partners in the middle east and beyond
uh to compare notes uh on iran's status
on iran's progress
and we will make a determination
based on what is in our national
interests and what's in the national
security interests
of our allies and partners this meeting
is going to happen just four or five
days after the board of governors the
bog uh meeting and
at the iaea there had been a push ahead
of today's announcement to get the board
of got the governors to actually censure
iran or to bring a resolution of
con if not condemnation of you know
pretty much extreme disapproval for
their their activities that have been
going on outside of the the deal and in
violation of other commitments that
they've made to the iaea
is that something you guys are prepared
to
forgo
now
will you we will you
will will you seek to censure them at
the board of governors before
the indirect talks begin in vienna uh so
i don't want to get ahead of uh the
board of governors what i can say is
that we have uh the full uh we have full
confidence uh in the iaea we have full
confidence in director general grossi of
the iaea but this doesn't have to do
with the actual idea this has to do with
the board of governors which is
something that you're on even though
you're no longer in the deal it's
something that the the
yeah and if you ask the director general
as you do i know he says this isn't up
to me this is up to the members
so it is up to the members to decide
whether they're going to bring a
resolution to censure iran
and this meeting is going to happen on i
think on the 24th of the 25th which is
four or five days before the
now we understand the vienna talks are
going to begin so is the u.s interested
in pursuing
a rent a resolution of condemnation or
censure
ahead of the presumption i i was
speaking to our full faith and
confidence in the iaea because they too
as you know uh have produced reports on
iran's activities
in recent months we've expressed our
concern
at those
reports we've made clear that iran's
continued nuclear escalations are
unconstructive
that they are inconsistent with the
stated goal that iran has put forward of
um
seeking to return to mutual compliance
with the jcpoa uh we've also been very
clear that iran's nuclear provocations
and escalations won't provide iran
with any additional
negotiating leverage
when talks
resume but
as you know the board of governors is
set to meet i don't want to get ahead of
the board of governors but we've made
very clear where we stand on those
escalations
and our concern with them nazir
thank you very much ned it's a good
opportunity i have a few questions but
maybe short answer
number one do you have any update
towards the
taliban government
and the second question what is the
status of the afghan embassy in
washington dc
and
third question the passport agency in
kabul issuing a passport are these
recognized by the united nations united
states sorry and the last question the
p2 are siv visa
some people still in afghanistan left
behind
they tried to leave afghanistan but they
have difficulty number two the p2 visa
how long is going to take
did the state department started the
processing because some people they went
to the third country but still they have
a lot of difficulty
um thank you for those so so let me uh
see if i can address uh all of them uh
you asked about uh sivs and and p2s and
the processing um let me actually uh
take a step back and and provide uh an
update there on our uh efforts to
facilitate uh the departure of uh those
whom we have a special commitment and
that of course includes uh american
citizens that includes lawful permanent
residents and that includes afghans who
have worked for and with us over the
years
as of today
we have assisted the departure of 377
u.s citizens and 279 lawful permanent
residents that's in addition
to a number of afghans to whom we have a
special commitment uh there have been uh
two
additional flights to flights yesterday
again our goal is to routinize these
operations so that those who wish
to leave afghanistan have additional
options to do so the united states will
continue to directly support the efforts
of american citizens of lawful permanent
residents of uh afghans to whom we have
a special commitment uh to do that again
if they so choose
that gets us to your question uh
regarding uh the production of uh
passports uh we welcome the production
and provision of travel documents we
know that
travel documents are
an important
in many cases a prerequisite to travel
including across borders
we know this is important for
uh we've heard from the taliban that's
important that people
be
documented we know from our partners in
the region as well
the priority they place on ensuring that
those who transit through their
countries have appropriate travel
documents and that is why
we do welcome
the production
of
of passports
we are continuing to
process siv applicants special immigrant
visa applicants at all
stages of the application process
when it comes to siv holders
those who have completed the process
we have uh been able to work with
a number of them to facilitate their
departure uh from afghanistan if they uh
have chosen to do so but uh again uh for
everyone at every single stage of the
process uh we are continuing uh to
uh support them and for those who are
beyond
a certain stage in the process we are
looking at processing alternatives uh
knowing that uh we are no longer able to
provide uh consular access and consular
support
on the ground uh in kabul although we do
uh have a team on the ground in doha
that
where we are working many of these
issues as well when it comes to the
afghan government we've been watching
very closely um uh their conduct uh
because the point we've always made uh
it is that it is not a question
of what we hear from them uh it is a
question of what we see them do
and this goes back to some of the very
issues we were speaking to before
the united states but also our allies
and our partners
around the world have set forth a series
of expectations
that we
need to see from the taliban that we
would need to see from any future
afghan government and among those
expectations
are
freedom of movement and safe passage for
those who do
wish to leave afghanistan to go back to
your question
but also the protection of human rights
uh including for uh women and girls
ethnic minorities uh and others in uh
afghanistan uh the um uh
the uh facilitation of humanitarian aid
humanitarian access not standing in the
way of the much needed supplies and
assistance
for the people of uh afghanistan and on
that score the united states as you may
know uh just a couple days ago announced
an additional 174 million dollars uh in
humanitarian assistance bringing uh our
total humanitarian uh assistance in 2021
uh to some 474 million dollars
as i recall some 4.2 billion dollars
since um
uh 2001
so we will continue uh to watch uh very
closely
as
the taliban
does or does not live up to its
commitments
and we've also been very clear that we
want to see a future
future government in afghanistan
that is
inclusive
that represents
the will of
the people of afghanistan and again that
importantly upholds the rights of all of
afghanistan's
citizens missy afghan embassy
the last one is the stats of the afghan
embassy in washington i don't believe
there's been any change to that status
thank you
uh nate i'd like to ask you about the
nso group
the entity designation
what can you say about what the state
department or the u.s government
knows about americans or people with u.s
numbers being
hacked or being targeted for hacking um
as part of the nso or the the other firm
i believe it's called kandiro
um
and there was a report about um
a report from israel saying that the by
administration gave the israeli
government only an hour advanced notice
of this designation
um is that true and it sort of gets to
the question i'm hoping you can address
what um in you know what does what can
you say about the israeli government's
knowledge of the activities um that nso
was conducting um including against
people who the united states has
advocated for in terms of you know
political activists and human rights
defenders and all of that thank you
sure
so
broadly speaking let me just
level that and make sure everyone is is
following the issue you referred to
this is that today
the u.s government added four entities
for foreign companies i should say to
the department of commerce's
entity list for engaging activities
contrary to the national security or
foreign policy interests of the united
states this follows an october 2021
interim final rule uh published by the
department of congress commerce
establishing controls of certain items
that can be used for malicious cyber
activities uh the four entities are
located in israel
russia and singapore when it comes to
the two companies that you mentioned the
nso group and candiru
they were added to the entity list
because investigative information has
shown that these companies developed and
supplied spyware to foreign governments
that
used tools to maliciously target
government officials
journalists business people activists
academics academics and embassy workers
nso group developed and supplied this
tool so pegasus as it's known
to governments that used it to
maliciously target government officials
journalists business people activists
academic academics and embassy personnel
it's important to note that we are not
taking actions against any countries uh
in which the four entities are located
or the governments uh themselves uh this
is about the conduct of these uh private
companies when it comes to
the notifications that were involved in
this action look i don't want to speak
to
um
or discuss private diplomatic
conversations
other than to note that as is the case
with all announcements of this kind
partner governments are notified uh in
advance and that was the case here okay
just uh the first question was do you
know can you say whether or not the us
government has knowledge that americans
including allegedly rob mali were
targeted by um nso i i think you would
understand why we just wouldn't uh
entertain that that question from here
uh but as i said before um investigative
information had led uh the u.s
government to conclude uh that these
private entities
should be listed under the department of
department of commerce entity list and
we did confirm and announce that today
are you elected to see against israel
will there be any punitive measures uh
so there are uh punitive measures
against these companies uh and uh the
inclusion of these companies
on the entity list is itself a powerful
tool
the entity list
is used by the department of commerce's
bureau of industry
and security to restrict the export
re-export an in-country transfer of
items subject to the export
administration regulations
to
persons and that includes to individuals
to organizations to companies reasonably
believed to be involved have been
involved or pose a significant risk
to being or becoming involved
in activities contrary to the national
security or foreign policy interests of
the united states so it does impose
additional restrictions on these
entities yes just to follow up you know
you say that this is not obviously not
imposed on a country but um
nso group
has
uh export licenses granted by the
israeli military you know you've got a
really close ally that
has
granted licenses to this company you
know do you expect
them to take action in in response to
these the investigative findings that
you've you've got here and have you
shared those with uh with israel or the
israeli military well look uh is israel
of course
is a steadfast friend
a steadfast partner
in that vein we have we have raised this
conduct with uh of these companies
with the government of israel and we
look forward to further discussions
with the government of israel about
ensuring that these companies products
are not used to target human rights
defenders
journalists and others who should be
protected
against you know entities in their
country that are carrying out ransomware
and cyber attacks on the us why wouldn't
you ask israel to do the same thing uh
well i think in this case you're
referring to
um criminals uh private criminal actors
uh in russia uh and we've been very
clear that every responsible country has
an obligation uh to take action against
criminals operating within their
territory uh in this case uh we are
talking about uh conduct of private
companies that we see as contrary
to our national security interests we
have
had conversations
with our israeli partners about the
conduct of the nso group uh we will
continue to have those conversations
in private to make clear our concerns
yes
press from brazil
brazil has announced new goals and
commitments on the climate issues these
days in the cup
and called this new announcement can
help the
to improve the relations between brazil
and the us in advanced partnerships and
create new partnerships or the us are
awaiting more bold movements and
effective results from brazil to advance
thank you so uh
in the run-up to
cop 26 uh
including in the climate summit
that the president convened
some weeks ago
and since
we have seen a number of uh bold
commitments from countries uh around the
world uh the united states uh in our own
commitments
by announcing that
we would reduce our emissions by between
50 and 52 percent by 2030. uh our goal
was not only to help stave off the
existential threat of climate change
but to have a catalytic impact and to
galvanize uh action on the part of
governments uh around the world uh we
know that countries that are
among the world's um
leading emitters uh the united states uh
certainly falls in that category brazil
certainly falls in that category we have
a special
responsibility to do what we can
again to combat the climate crisis but
also to demonstrate leadership and to
demonstrate uh action
so commitments are important
follow-through
is also important i suspect that as cop
26 continues for
the next week and a half or so
we will hear additional commitments from
countries around the world
knowing that
this is what the president has called
the decisive decade
the action that we take now or
the inaction
that
we see now
will be determinative
in terms of our ability or not
to keep global global warming
below 1.5 degrees celsius
the level at which scientists have told
us
is
absolutely imperative uh if we are to
stave off uh the worst effects
of climate change uh so we welcome
announcements from countries around the
world we continue uh to urge uh our
partners
to
raise their climate ambition uh knowing
that only by doing so uh will we be able
to make good uh on the commitments that
were put forward in paris uh some uh
years ago now um but even more
importantly uh to stave off the worst
effects of climate change knowing that
this is the decisive decade
sure
thank you
mr blinken mentioned that president
ghani has been agreed with him to
andover the power to the taliban
government without fight
but when ghani escapes everything got
changed if it was agreed before that
taliban come to the power then what is
the difference
i don't know you got my
i do i do so this is something that uh
we have spoken to secretary blinken has
has uh spoken to this uh our former uh
special representative for afghanistan
uh
has also spoken to this but in the days
prior to the collapse of the afghan
government that was precipitated by
president ghani's decision to flee the
country
we were engaged in intense intense
diplomacy
with our afghan partners with the ghani
government
but also with the taliban
on a means by which
to
stave off what we feared could be
massive violence uh if uh the taliban's
military offensive continued uh and so
there was uh there were discussions uh
and there was uh a framework in place
that we believe uh could have
transitioned power
to a government
that included the taliban but was also
inclusive and representative
of the afghan people
to us uh
that would have been uh a means by which
to protect some of the important gains
uh over the past uh 20 years including
uh for afghanistan's people its women
its minorities
while staving off the potential for
violence now of course
with the fall of the afghan government
with the
steady advances
of the taliban
that
diplomacy uh those discussions uh became
for naught but again our emphasis on
seeing to it that any future afghan
government uh
respects the rights of its people
is representative of the will of its
people
our emphasis on that has uh not abated
at all it continues to be
a guiding principle for our engagement
with the taliban it continues to be a
guiding principle
in our discussions with allies and
partners and you've heard that same
message put forward from our allies and
partners to the taliban as well we'll
take a final quick question
officials
have
reportedly say turkey brought the s 400
missile batteries to angelic air base
where uh the us and nato
and nato forces are
can you confirm that and
what's your comment on it i'm sorry i
didn't hear the first part of your
question that turkey
brought the s-400 uh missile system to
that
ah got it got it um
uh
look
we have been uh quite clear on our
position uh regarding the s-400 and in
turkey uh as you know president biden
and president erdogan uh has not had an
opportunity uh within the past uh couple
days in rome uh to uh have a bilateral
discussion uh president biden uh
reaffirmed our defense partnership and
turkey's importance as a nato ally um
but in that meeting the president also
noted uh concerns over turkey's
possession
of the russian s 400 uh missile uh
system so we've made our concerns with
this system very clear we've made the
implications uh of that uh possession of
the s 400 very clear as well including
in the context of the f-35
program can i correct something that i
said just for france this is a welcome
change yeah yeah yeah yeah so it was uh
sorry i said i i think i said in a
question earlier that that addis and
embassy addison north is cartoon that
was wet to authorize departure last
wednesday not at us that's correct sorry
okay thank you very much
[Music]
chris
have they called for the gather yet over
there
what do you say
san is manhattan